I suppose a lot of people there are more
home trees where that came from and
sometimes let's be honest the truth can
hurt nothing was off limits in this
interview no tough questions were pulled
Ronaldo answers them all with a brutal
honesty very seldom seen from a star of
his renounce
days before the football World Cup
football's biggest ever star has rocked
the sporting World we're running it
they're talking about it you can see the
entire interview interview to Piers
Morgan just breaking in England an
exclusive interview between Pierce
Morgan and Cristiano Ronaldo she's done
this huge high-profile interview it's
now gone outside of sport football media
outside of sports media and now is in
mainstream news reports Cristiano
Ronaldo who has said he is being
betrayed by his Club the 37 year old's
comments were made during an interview
with Piers Morgan for talk TV Ronaldo
releases the intro to a interview he has
with Pierce Morgan you got on there on
Twitter and you tweeted Ronaldo I don't
respect the manager Ronaldo who uh
missed today because of illness uh but
has also done any uh an interview with
Piers Morgan Bill Cristiano Ronaldo has
accused Manchester United off between
him in an interview there has been a
huge reaction to this interview before
it's even gone to air it's one of the
most explosive interviews certainly that
I've ever done tens of millions of
people have already viewed the two short
clips we released last night and there
are more fireworks coming later this
evening because Ronaldo speaks people
listen he's not just in my view the
greatest footballer of all time he's a
global Mega star
he's of course highly paid too and he's
extremely commercially viable to any
club sales of his shirts at Manchester
United broke all records within 24 hours
of him going back
and after a year in which many people
including some of his ex-teammates have
blamed him for the decline at Manchester
United he simply decided he'd had enough
they're trying to force you out yes not
only the coach but the other two or
three guys there around
the club at the senior executive level
yes that I felt betrayed
and you think they're trying to get rid
of you honestly I shouldn't say that I
don't know but listen I I don't care I'm
always people should listen the truth
yes I feel betrayed and I felt that some
people that don't want me here not only
this year but last year too well already
the interviews deeply divided opinion uh
amongst fans and wider football
supporters the club has released a
statement today saying it will consider
its response from the full facts have
been established which I take to mean
after they've watched the whole
interview but Ronaldo makes clear
throughout our conversation utmost
respect for Manchester United's history
as a club and for its supporters he's as
frustrated about the stagnation of the
once biggest football team in the world
as they are that's why he's speaking out
because as he sees it the club hasn't
moved forward at all since he left 13
years ago I don't know what's going on
but since
since the saralex Ferguson left I saw
not evolution in the club the progress
was Zero
for example you have a interesting point
that how the club as Manchester United
after suck
um Ole they buy they bring sport
directive Ralph regnick which is
something that nobody understands this
guy is not even a coach
a bigger club like Manchester United
bring sport directive surprise not only
me but all the worlds you know nothing
changed surprisingly natural only the
pool the jacuzzi even the gym
even some points of Technology the
kitchen
the chefs which is I appreciate lovely
lovely persons they stop in a in a time
which is
it surprised me a lot I thought I will
see different things different as I
mentioned before technology
infrastructure but unfortunately we see
many
things that I'm used to see when I was
20 21 23 so surprised me a lot
they suppose a lot of people there are
more home truths where that came from
and sometimes let's be honest the truth
can hurt nothing was off limits in this
interview no tough questions were pulled
Ronaldo answers them all with a brutal
honesty very seldom seen from a star of
his Renown A lot's already been written
and said about this interview just based
on the small amount we've already
revealed a lot of it I have to say is
ill-informed bile a lot of it is just
plain fake news the only way you'll find
out what Ronaldo really says is by
watching the whole interview here on
Wednesday and Thursday and I think he'll
change a lot of people's minds when they
do it's something that I regret to the
left from the stadium probably or maybe
no I don't know it's difficult to
to tell you 100
if I'm
but let's say I regret
but in the same way I felt uh provoked
by the coach I'm not allowed for me
a coach to put me in three minutes in
the game Sorry I'm not that kind of
player I know what I can give to the
teams you're talking about the Tottenham
thing the Tottenham yeah I'm talking
about in pre-season it was a friendly
where you left the ground with a several
of me and eight players right so that
they mentioned only my name yeah which
is his
everyone do that I don't understand why
they mentioned only about about high
value kind of play a game
last year many players do the same in
that game eight players do it the same
so but they only speak about the black
Chip which is me which is I completely
understand okay it's done I apologize to
the coach and for me
the chapter was was closed you didn't
have a good relationship with him I'm
not mean good relationship the empathy
is not it's not good let's say you think
he respects you
I think you don't you don't respect the
way I should deserve
but
it is what it is this is why probably
the the game against Tottenham well I
want to come to these two games so
against Manchester City where United got
destroyed
he didn't bring you on
he brought another strike it was but
didn't bring you on
and
I felt insulted on your behalf I was
like look surely against Manchester City
if you're losing this badly and you've
got the greatest player of all time
sitting there you at least give him some
time don't you but he didn't and he said
afterwards the reason was he had too
much respect for you he wanted to
respect you when you heard him say that
what did you think
excuses
I say as excuses
I sell many things that
I don't wanna I don't want to criticize
him it can it can have different opinion
than me that they choose the players
that I think is better for the team I
respect that but the excuse is all the
time you know the excuses have short
legs you cannot excuse all the time
which is things that don't make sense
okay you don't put me against Manchester
City because of respect of your career
and you want to put me three minutes
against daughter well that's the thing
so then you then play Tottenham don't
make sense and then he wants to bring
you on with three minutes to go which is
the complete opposite to what he said
the situation was with City I think it
did it did it did purpose because for
example in the national team the other
clubs if the coach want to put me five
minutes if someone injured or or if they
really need me I will help but in that
way I felt provoked not only because of
that game but before somebody he was
deliberately provoking it right for
everyone everyone know that
disrespecting you think exactly this is
why I say I don't have respect for him
because they don't show me respect for
me this is why
we we are we are in that situation we
show a lack of ambition to you when they
replaced Ole Gunner solskar who a lot of
fans liked but he obviously wasn't
delivering the big titles that United
wanted and were used to
but to a point someone like Ralph Randy
I mean I'd never heard of him
and I'm thinking about it and I'm
thinking if as you heard of him no of
course not you've never heard of this
guy nobody and the people who I speak
nobody knew it it was him suddenly he's
did you call him the boss
of course I I respect we have to call
because he assume the the job
regardless the all the coaches that I
had in my career I call them boss
because if they assume the the job we
have to call in that way then in the end
deep inside me I I never saw him as a
boss because I saw some points that
I never agreed and he's stopped in the
time as well because if you're not
being a coach the the last the next five
years you're gonna you know you're gonna
lost the identity of to be a coach so
surprised me a lot but in the same way
don't surprise me a lot because if you
see the structures just keep they keep
in the same so the coaches didn't
surprise me but was a tough moment
you're number one for me thank you he's
number two you're number one to you he's
number two
um but it's an amazing relationship you
have even though you're not I know great
friends or anything but you're always
respectful when you see each other but
what do you think of him Messina as you
both head to maybe your last work as a
football player yeah and as a person
amazing player is Magic top
as a person we share the state
16 years imagine 16 years
we are the highest we share so I have
great relationship with him I'm not
friend of him in terms of when I mean
friend is the guy who is with you in
your house or speaking the phone no but
it's like a teammate he's a guy that I
really respect the way he always speak
about me
even his wife or my wife my girlfriend
they always respect and they're from
Argentina my girlfriend is from
Argentina so good what I'm gonna say
about Mexico great things he's a good
guy is you do everything for football
the best player you've ever seen
excluding yourself
probably yes
um
zidane probably
yes that I
play fight with him yes have you ever
had dinner together never would you like
to why not you lost your baby son and
now your baby daughter's in hospital
exactly and you must have been
absolutely directive of
and the president of Manchester United
and then
kind of that didn't believe
that something going wrong which is make
me feel bad really yes I am yes I didn't
believe you
they believe you but in the same way
they are there
and never be ever gonna change
the health of my family
for the football never
now or
10 years
behind or forward and it's something
that really hurt me because they doubt
of my words that I struggle especially
Bell and Jill we had one week in
hospital because the Bell have a big
problem
and I didn't go to the preseason because
of that because I didn't I didn't
was allowed to left my family if
something happened
to do the Precision because I think it
wasn't not fair to left my family for a
preseason this is why I didn't go